[Musique]
je
bonjour à toutes et à tous j'aimerais
essayer une petite expérience inspiré de
kimberley crenshaw avec vous et pour ça
je vais demander à toutes celles et ceux
qui le peuvent de se lever
je vais vous s'il vous plaît merci je
vais citer le nom de père pour chacun de
ces noms si vous ne le connaissez pas ne
pouvait rien dire on n'en avait jamais
entendu parler avant
vous pourrez vous rasseoir attention à
la fin de la liste nous verrons ce que
ça celles et ceux restés debout au quai
napoléon bonaparte
christophe colomb abraham lincoln
simone de beauvoir
si vous êtes encore debout j'aimerais
que vous regardez autour de vous il
reste à peu près toute la salle encore
debout en tout cas plus de la moitié
très bien continuer martin luther king
frantz fanon d'accord toussaint
louverture d'accord harriet tubman
concrètement si vous regardez autour de
la salle maintenant il n'y a plus
personne debout si je me trompe pas donc
pour celles et ceux d'entre vous qui ont
reconnu les personnes citées dans la
première liste
vous savez qu'il s'agissait de
personnages historiques ayant marqué
l'histoire de l'humanité et des
relations entre les peuples et aussi
entre les hommes et les femmes ce qui
est intéressant de remarquer c'est que
ceux cités dans la deuxième liste était
également des personnages historiques
ayant marqué l'histoire de l'égalité
entre les peuples
la seule différence principale qui
distingue s du premier groupe de ceux du
2e et la pigmentation de leur peau et
cela donnerait à penser que c'est la
raison pour laquelle ceux du deuxième
groupe leur existence et leurs oeuvres
sont si peu connu est presque
inexistante des programmes scolaires que
leurs vies et leurs voix sont quasiment
ignorés dans l'effort de mémoire
indispensable à l'inclusion de plus de
diversité dans nos représentants
historiques dans nos leaders politiques
dans nos managers et dans nos modèles
habituels
ceci explique également les voix et les
opinions que l'on entend très souvent
versus les voix et les opinions que l'on
entend quasiment jamais qui ne font pas
partie de notre définition de la dce de
la diversité qui sont constamment
discriminés et c'est ainsi que naissent
les préjugés inconscient quand j'avais
11 ans j'ai été agressé par une personne
qui m'a clairement dit qu'elle n'aimait
pas les noirs comme moi mais cela n'a
pas été suffisant pour que j'ouvre les
yeux sur l'intolérance des différences
et des divergences ambiante
je pensais comme la plupart des gens
autour de moi que les discriminations la
colonisation les gars de couleur de peau
que tout ça appartenait au passé
comme la plupart des horreurs et erreur
humaine compter dans le livre d'histoire
c'est seulement plus tard que j'ai
réalisé que les préjugés inconscient
issus de notre histoire
les discriminations ordinaires ne sont
pas limités à la couleur de la peau car
quand j'avais 24 ans j'ai eu la chance
de faire un volontariat international en
entreprise 1 veilleux dans mon pays
d'origine le cameroun en travaillant et
en vivent là bas en tant que mini
exploit trier j'ai pu vivre et voir les
inégalités considérables qui existent
encore entre nous français privilégiés
oui français privilégiés pardon et l
les populations locales qui ne
bénéficient encore que très peu des
nombreuses richesses qu'à offrir le
cameroun comme la plupart des pays du
sud
et c'est aussi là que j'ai découvert que
cela ne me concernait pas que moi mais
qu'il existait de nombreuses études
internationales sociologique sur les sur
les résultats des discriminations
partout dans le monde dans diverses
sociétés et de haut niveau global dans
la continuité de ces discriminations il
existe également l'intersexualité à
savoir la situation d'une personne qui
subit à la fois plusieurs types de
discriminations en même temps car à
l'heure du féminisme et du calcul
incessant de la parité
à l'heure de la libération de la parole
et du soutien à la cause lgbt qu on
parle souvent des inégalités qui
existent entre les hommes et les femmes
dont je suis une grande défenseuse
également mais qu'en est il des
inégalités qui existent entre noirs et
blancs entre personnes handicapées et
personnes dites normales entre immigrés
ou potentiels immigrés et français voire
européens et descendants d'européens ou
potentiels expatriés ou encore entre
riches et pauvres
durant mon séjour au cameroun
j'ai également eu le malheur de voir ma
cousine k reen négligé et laissée pour
morte dans sa vie ne valait rien aux
yeux du personnel médical local et si
karine est morte si subitement fait que
son genre sa classe sociale modeste
et également sa couleur de peau n'ont
pas aidé lorsqu'il a fallu valoriser
l'importance de son existence et de sa
vie un peu comme le système scolaire a
ignoré de valoriser l'importance de la
vie de personne comme harriet tubman qui
a pourtant sauvé des dizaines d'esclaves
à elle seule alors qu'elle était n'est
elle-même esclaves et c'est cet épisode
traumatique qui m'a fait prendre
conscience de la profondeur des
discriminations des inégalités et des
préjugés ma cousine karine était une
femme noire revenus plutôt modeste est
rentré également dans la catégorie de
potentiel immigrés car c'était une femme
loire camerounaise c'est dans le jargon
des afo féministes des féministes qui
prennent également en compte des
inégalités liées à la race au genre au
sexe à l'orientation sexuelle à la
classe sociale et à la situation de
handicap et j'en passe que l'on dit que
ma cousine karine avait une grande
intersectionnelle é tait car elle
subissait en même temps plusieurs formes
de discrimination ordinaire à la fois et
découvrir l'intersexualité et ce qui m'a
permis de réaliser l'importance des
discriminations et le fait que nous
pouvons également l'échangé cependant
pardon c'est un sujet un peu sensible
pour moi découvert leur sexualité et ce
qui m'a permis d'apporter plus de
diversité dans ma recherche de figures
auxquelles m'identifier est également en
ce qui concerne les histoires que je
choisi de retenir ou de croire comme par
exemple dans cette histoire trois
médecins ont d'art jeune frère robert
qui lui pourtant affirme ne pas avoir
deux frères dans cette histoire qui ment
eh bien personne robert à trois soeurs
mais soyons honnêtes
combien d'entre nous n'ont pas imaginé
trois hommes lorsque j'ai mentionné ces
trois médecins mais ne vous inquiétez
pas je vous comprends car il est
vraiment difficile d'inclure plus de
diversité dans notre représentation du
monde lorsque tous les modèles
classiques qui ne sont proposées au
niveau global dans les médias ont tous
le même genre la même couleur de peau la
même forme de corps et le même type
d'intelligence mais question que se
passerait-il si au lieu de juger les
gens par ses multiples critères non
pertinents on prenait en compte toute la
diversité possible et imaginable dans
nos emplois et dans nos managers les
entreprises qui inclut plus de diversité
dans leur direction ont été étudiées car
les études prenant en compte les
discriminations dans les emplois sont
les plus étudiés au monde et ses études
montrent que c'est toute la société qui
perd lorsqu on n'exploite pas une partie
des cerveaux ou que les employés ne
s'est pas exprimé toute leur idée car
ils ne se sentent pas assez représentée
auprès de leurs managers qui ne leur
ressemblent pas de plus les entreprises
qui a inclus plus de diversité dans leur
direction ont tendance à avoir de
meilleurs résultats
car ils connaissent mieux leur clientèle
qui elle représente l'arc en ciel entier
de l'humanité et de la société
j'aimerais donc vous inviter à imaginer
les bénéfices pour tous de l'inclusion
de chacun de nous dans la recherche de
solutions aux plus grands progrès
me sociaux environnementaux du moment en
effet les entreprises qui inclut plus de
diversité dans leurs managers font en
moyenne 20% de profits de plus grâce à
leurs innovations et celles qui optent
pour la diversité ethnique et culturelle
font 33% à 33 % plus de chances d'avoir
des profits au dessus de la moyenne
ainsi il est indispensable de prendre
conscience dès maintenant que les
discriminations existent encore un nous
et qu un travail actif est nécessaire
pour s'en défaire les discriminations
existent également
car aujourd'hui nous vivons dans un
système où les voies sont t'écoute sont
comptés mais n'ont pas écouté les
discriminations existent en eau au
niveau personnel comme au niveau
collectif et parfois même elle nous
empêche de nous écouter nous même et
elle nous empêche de réaliser
l'importance des vies et des voix de
chacun de nous et là quelle est la place
de la démocratie et que faire face à ce
constat amer c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui
en plus de vous parler de comment le
manque de diversité dans la démocratie
est la cause de tous nos problèmes de
société car jamais un seul type de
personne ne pourra les régler j'aimerais
aussi vous inviter à prendre une bouffée
d'oxygène pour plonger dans un rêve de
démocratie pertinentes comme au danemark
en islande ou en suisse la démocratie
pertinente c'est quand on cherche avant
tout à améliorer la vie de chacun sans
pour autant se reposer systématiquement
sur les mêmes représentants classique
dans ce système on commence par
s'assurer de prendre en compte toute la
diversité existantes dans le groupe
concerné et j'ai également de questions
honnêtement
n'est-il pas l'heure de plus de
diversité n'est-il pas temps de cesser
d'évaluer les compétences en fonction
des origines des horizons critères non
pertinents tout d'abord quand je dis
diversité ce que je veux dire c'est
demos le peuple nom masculin singulier
dans lequel sont enfermés 70 millions de
femmes et d'hommes tous différents mais
qui sont tous français
d'ailleurs tous différents et qui pour
moi pourrait chacun être
président d'une petite part de france eh
bien oui puisque nous sommes 70 millions
et bien moi je rêve qu'il y ait 70
millions de président chacun responsable
de sa petite part de france comme chaque
partie du corps humain qui est
différente mais nécessaires au bon
fonctionnement du tout et comme si on
partageait tous le pouvoir et le travail
et quand je dis pouvoir ce que je veux
dire c'est cratie créativité la
possibilité que pour chaque question
chaque personne puisse se créer la
solution qui lui convient tout en effet
à tous ses concitoyens qui souffre des
mêmes choses
car si j'ai bien appris quelque chose en
tant qu'ingénieur c'est que pour trouver
une vraie solution
y a pas plus créatifs et pertinents que
la personne qui vit le problème en
grandeur nature au quotidien et pour qui
c'est une question de vie ou de mort car
enfin l'urgence du changement
démocratique nous rappelle que chacun de
nous doit cultiver sa singularité et
parler ouvertement
mais avec bienveillance des
discriminations existantes autour de lui
car autrement nous n'aurons plus un
problème de vivre ensemble mais plutôt
de mourir ensemble car sans diversité
il n'y a pas de vie créative et si vous
vous demandez comment
eh bien on inclut un maximum d'un père
sectional ite
car à cette heure ci tous les ingénieurs
connaissent le clustering et les big
data des techniques permettant la
participation démocratique directe et en
quelques clics
mais trop peu d'entre eux sont deux
jeunes femmes noires de banlieue
atypique donc exclue sans réseau est
sans emploi
donc voilà c'est pourquoi je pense que
comme un seul corps là maintenant tout
de suite
il est temps de rassembler toutes nos
divergences pour enfin bénéficier de
toute la créativité qu'offre notre
diversité et afin aussi de générer les
150 milliards d'euros que nous coûte le
manque de diversité dans nos entreprises
de france pays pourtant si cosmopolite
et oui 150 milliards d'euros c'est le
coût économique du manque et de
l'abandon des hauts potentiels diverses
à la tête de nos institutions clé
aujourd'hui et c'est brutal comme le
quotidien de millions de françaises et
français systématiquement exclus donc
voilà le rêve
réveillons nous allons-y les citoyens
les gens les étudiants les jeunes
arrêtons de nous opposer et de diverger
regroupons nous un démocratie pertinente
grâce à trois actions clés plus d'abord
une prise de conscience prendre
conscience que les discriminations
existent encore aujourd'hui car nous
vivons dans un système discriminatoire
la démocratie actuelle nous invite à
choisir des représentants qui au final
ne représente qu'un seul type de
personne alors que nous sommes 8
milliards d'êtres humains différents sur
la planète et 70 millions en france avec
une magnifique diversité ethnique d'âge
de deux d'orientation sexuelle et d'
handicap et j'en passe prenons
conscience de notre propre
intersectionnelle it et 6 plutôt
discriminés ou suis-je plutôt privilégié
quel est le degré de diversité autour de
moi et dans mes représentants classique
deuxièmement grâce à la prise de parole
est ce que j'ouvre la voie plus de
personnes issues des minorités visibles
et invisibles
est ce que j'écoute les parties de moi
même qui sont discriminés et ce que je
parle ouvertement des discriminations et
de leur impact négatif sur la société
comme beaucoup d'entreprises en france
aujourd'hui qui ont fait le choix de
plus de diversité
je vous invite à exprimer à promouvoir
la non discrimination et troisièmement
par la prise d'actions
est ce que je recherche de la diversité
dans mes représentants classique est ce
que j'exprime honnêtement ma singularité
est-ce que je prends la responsabilité
de mes préjugés inconscient afin de les
changer
donc voilà en conclusion il faut se
rappeler que les discriminations
existent en nous mais qu'un travail est
nécessaire pour s'en défaire et aider
les autres à s'en défaire également de
plus lutter contre les discriminations
n'est pas seulement quelque chose de
bien
cela permet également de créer plus de
richesse de sagesse de savoir et de
l'innovation pour nous tous et si vous
pensez que c'est impossible alors inclus
et nous tous et moi et mon honnêteté
pour qu'ensemble on vous montre ce qu'on
sait faire depuis l'époque du cartable
dans nos cités à savoir créer de l'unité
n'ont pas malgré mais bel et bien grâce
à de la diversité merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]